so you're involved in this united city
campaign in manchester
what is it trying to achieve i think
it's trying to take control of the
messaging locally
um i think that eight months after this
virus starting we first went into
lockdown
to not have a clear plan out of this is
something that we're finding difficult
to understand why and we're frustrated
and
i think that obviously we've been
putting the toughest tears which is
something that
again brings greater
problems for us i mean we've got
economic problems got health problems
uh mental health issues there's a lack
of um
understanding of how we're going to come
out of it uncertainty
and we just felt the business community
in manchester has always been resilient
manning unions have always come together
to come out of crises like this before
and it's about time now that we started
to think about how the future looks
short medium and long term you have to
be part of a lot of groups a lot of
campaigns but this one it just felt like
there was a group of
about 120 of us now who just felt that
we weren't getting the messaging that we
wanted from
from government and you of course run
hotels in manchester so your businessman
there
how's it been it must be been really
hard it's shocking
it's shocking to be i have to say the
whole hospitality sector has been
devastated and i split it probably into
two parts
with the restrictions in place we're
purely in a defensive position
we need more support the furlough helps
but there does need to be other economic
support packages put in place
for all hospitality whilst we're in
these restrictions
and even then coming out of the
restrictions it isn't then going to end
there needs to be support in place the
vat help the business rates relief
helped
um that there's no doubt but they need
to continue to allow they've racked up
more debt during this period
and i worry about the next 12 months
there's going to need to be
a fair wind with us we certainly cannot
continue to keep moving in and out of
tears the way which we are else it's
just a complete devastation on people's
livelihoods and of course the greater
manchester in particular
you've been under title restrictions for
an awfully long time now
yeah i think only three weeks without
restrictions i think it's the worst hit
city
i don't think people are great to manage
have a problem with restrictions if it's
saving people's lives
they have a problem with restrictions
that aren't then um
you know where the economic package and
support isn't in place to actually align
with what's happening
you know people losing their jobs
livelihoods are being lost it's
affecting
the disadvantaged and the vulnerable
most the hospitality sector
who works in the hospitality sector who
props it up it's young people it's the
it's the lowest paid workers and they're
the people who need the income
badly and they're not getting the income
and
you know we had 250 people working in
our hotels before this pandemic
at this moment in time there isn't any
work there there isn't any work there
the pa
the the part-time staff who come in the
weekend to work on match day say for
instance around hotel football
we don't have match days so we've just
got a real big problem that's brewing
there isn't any
pathway out of it and that is the big
frustration that's why united city was
sent up we need to change the direction
of the messaging
and have a clear way out of this because
it can't continue to go on as you say
250 people straight away whose
livelihoods depend on on the future of
what happens there
so just to be clear is it the
restrictions that you've got a problem
with or is it the fact that there's not
enough economic support along with it
i don't have a problem with the
restrictions uh in respect of
we need to save lives health must be the
priority and clearly there is
high covert in manchester i think there
is high culvert in manchester in certain
aspects pockets have managed to very
high cases
and in other parts there isn't it's this
blanket approach the whole of greater
manchester which i think has been
applied to london and other areas as
well
um the restrictions i think aren't a
problem
but the lack of support and the lack of
planning to come out of it is the big
problem
the uncertainty i'll give one example
where in ter three
we're being told currently that we will
be told whether we're going into tier
two on the 16th of december
and that we can open hospitality on the
19th how can that be
we can't order the food in time you
can't open your booking engines how can
people plan you can't mobilize your
staff
so we're in a situation whereby there is
no plan everything's so
reactive and immediate and it cannot be
like that leadership can be
cannot be like that and i was critical
of the labour party earlier on in the
week because they're there to protect
the disadvantaged and the vulnerable and
the restrictions being in place which
protects health is fine
but they know that the economic support
isn't in place aligned with those
restrictions
which means you've got to take a
position and be bold and go against that
you cannot abstain
and that's where people have managed at
this moment in time i think are
frustrated with the lack of leadership
in i suppose protecting
the residents of manchester and the
communities that are hardest hit so
you'd like to see labour vote against a
tier system then
yeah i don't like half roads leadership
take us
take a stance you've got you know you go
out in your general election you're told
in your general election to all the
people on the doorsteps get out and vote
so when you're elected and you are in
that you're in that seat in west
westminster you just take a position
you don't abstain you take part in the
match you're the opposition
you're the opposition don't sit in the
stand they sat in the stand
whilst the home team had a clear run and
even they didn't have a clear run
because some of their own players got
sent out
quite a few cards in that match um
i've got to ask you what would you say
to people who say look footballers
should just stay out of politics stick
to football i'd have a problem with it
to be honest with you
the timeline is full of critics it's
full of people who support and i have no
issue with it
um i think that does everybody not feel
a little bit more political the last
couple of years
i think they do that's a good thing i
think people are more engaged maybe it's
because of the
the leaders that we've had in some of
the biggest countries in the world
they've been quite divisive or they've
engaged with people more
uh they've brought people's opinions to
the former i think brexit
i think covered the fact that we've been
at home watching government ministers
speaking every night on television
uh the fact that we have had nothing
else to do for three or four months and
other than to do that
i don't think it's a bad thing and
football players have an ability to be
able to connect
and leadership is about connecting and
you think of what football players have
done this last six months there was a
point earlier in the pandemic where i
think the health
minister suggested that footballers need
to do more
i don't think he would be saying that
today because footballers do try you
know
footballers generally are from uh
low-income families
from areas like dudley and berry and
barrow they're not from hampstead or
knightsbridge they're not from sort of
what would be wealthy families or
um you know rich families they're not
and they they
they're generally good people football
players they obviously have the faults
like everybody but they want people to
get by they want opportunities for all
they want equality they want
inclusion and to me there is too much
division
and i think that's where there is an
element of football players now becoming
more political ex-football players
becoming more political
because they see that it's an issue we
cannot have this division whereby we're
against each other we're at each other's
throats and you're either here or you're
here
we have to come back towards the middle
whereby we work as one and
at this moment in time we aren't working
as one as a nation we need to work
better
what do you think it says about our
political leaders uh the fact that
people like yourself people like marcus
rashford have felt that
actually you need to use your platform
to try and bring people together like
you've said and to try and make change
i i i've got no doubt how difficult it's
been in the last eight to ten months
being in government
i've got no doubt um it unique
circumstances
and i've been there where i was uh
the leader of a football club for four
months in valencia i was out my depth
and i was spinning and i had to just
jump off the roundabout because
ultimately i was out my depth and i
didn't know what i was doing
and that's why i feel the last eight
months i've seen in the leadership in
this country so you think they
have felt out of debt they're out of the
depth they're out of it the countries
who've
dealt with this really well have been
they've had definite and sure leaders
people who've been in control
composed clear plans clear communication
strategy
aggressive testing discipline tracing
they've had maybe border controls in
place early they've made decisions that
have been unpopular at times
but they've really handled the virus
well we're still eight months later none
the wiser
as to how our long term looks how our
short term looks how our medium term
looks
we're in manchester don't know whether
we're coming out of a lot down in two
weeks and if we come out of that
lockdown we don't know that we're going
back in it again two weeks later we've
gotta have a plan that surely works
well i've got you fans coming back into
stadiums this weekend
gonna see some fans back at premier
league matches
um but of course in tier three areas
there won't be any fans allowed back in
including of course for the manchester
clubs as well
it feels like a bit of a postcode
lottery do you think it's going to put
some clubs at a disadvantage
i don't believe personally it is um i
think that i'm happy to see fans come
back into stadiums
i do think this idea that salford city
if they were to come into theater in two
weeks can have 2 000 but manchester
united got 75 000 stadium
can have 2 000 is just madness i mean
surely manchester united can house more
than 2 000 people safely and socially
distance
at salford we might only be able to hold
1 200.
so again it's this blanket approach this
lack of bespoke
um approach to sort of different
situations
how do we deal with the hospitality
sector how do we deal with hospitality
do we want to close it we believe it
potentially causes health damage to us
okay we need a bespoke package for the
hospitality sector the travel sectors
that we know because we're putting
border restrictions in place we're not
allowing people to fly
okay this is the travel sector we're
gonna put up this boat package in place
it just seems to me to be a blanket
approach to everyone irrespective of the
good or the bad situation that you're in
and that's the same with football clubs
2 000 in a 10 000 stadium a 75 000
stadium or a 5 000 stadium
i'm happy about it it's the start you
know i know that we'll
they'll increase but it's the beginning
and we should be happy about it but
again it's just another
example of where you feel it's just a
case it's a bit lazy
it's a little bit lazy it's not really
leadership it's it's a goal just let
2000 back in where's the science behind
that
they always said they would look at the
science where is the science behind 2000
there can't be there can't be any
science thanks very much been really
fascinating to talk thank you